nous avons joint sur ce plateau ligne en
mêlée lilian bonsoir on va faire ce soir
un focus non pas sur un mais deux
cantons oui on commence à on vous
l'avait dit par un des cantons
chalonnais chalon 3 qui se caractérise
par un duel féminin gauche à droite
nathalie leblanc pour le ps face à
isabelle de chaume pour lui d y deux
femmes qui occupent des responsabilités
locales importantes et un nouvel épisode
après la bascule à droite de la ville de
chalon damien bouthillier et roméo a
chuté le nouveau canton de chalon 3
regroupe une partie de la ville de
chalon sur saône ainsi que la totalité
de châtenoy le royal
et dans cette dernière commune même si
madame le maire marie mercier ne se
présente pas elle fait tout de même
campagne pour les candidats de droite
un binôme qui se présente comme
complémentaires et unis le fait qu'elles
soient élus chacun sur ces deux communes
fait naturellement
on s'est réparti la tâche moi et mon et
mon suppléant qui suit chaque main basse
sur la commune de châtenoy et isabelle
sur la partie salon et c'est isabelle
est loin d'être une inconnue dont le
landerneau politique locale car outre
ses fonctions de délégué départemental
de l'ud dei
isabelle de chaume et surtout la
première adjointe au maire de chalon sur
saône alors celle qui a fait partie de
l'équipe qui a fait tomber christophe
sirugue se verrait bien continuer sur sa
lancée en sortant la conseillère
générale
proche de l'ancien maire même si elle
s'en défend suis pas dans ce genre de
combat nominem ça m'intéresse pas du
tout je suis pas là pour taper sur ce
qui s'est passé avant même si on a le
droit de constater qu'il ya des choses
qui ne vont pas il ya des choses qui
sont au point mort il ya des choses
qu'on peut avancer à nous trouver les
propositions qui seront pertinentes pour
la suite et le programme de ce binôme
ump udi se veut à la fois départemental
et ciblée locale mais je pense notamment
à l'accompagnement des personnes âgées
parce que on en a un certain nombre sur
le territoire mais pas seulement on a
aussi une vision sur l'accompagnement
des petites enfances sur les collèges
puisque nous avons deux collèges sur ce
canton
voilà c'est quelque chose d'assez
équilibrée parce que nous devons avoir
une solidarité des idées et propositions
sur l'intégralité du département du côté
du ps le binôme est calqué sur le même
schéma qu à droite pascal le goût est
conseiller municipal à châtenoy-le-royal
mais dans l'opposition
on quant à la chalonnaise nathalie
leblanc la conseillère générale sortante
elle a dû céder son poste d'adjointe au
maire de chalon lors des dernières
élections
ainsi face à face se trouve notamment
deux femmes à forte personnalité et
nathalie leblanc n'hésite pas attaquer
sur des vieux engagements de campagne
je me suis tenu aux engagements que
j'avais fait en 2008
ma principale adversaire ne le fait pas
parce que c'était largement engagée sur
le non cumul des mandats or dès qu'elle
a été élue en 2014 et bien s'est
empressé d'être à la fois première
adjointe au maire de chalon
vice-présidente du grand chalon le
président du centre de gestion
présidente déléguée de la mission locale
et maintenant elle brigue le mandat de
conseillère départementale pour moi
l'engagement politique c'est extrêmement
important pour que justement nos
concitoyens continuent de croire en eux
à gauche il ya donc du mort dont mais
surtout un bilan que nathalie leblanc
mais largement d'en avant un exemple là
c'est la réhabilitation du quartier des
aubépins du parc et des immeubles et des
appartements
mais si le bilan est très important en
revanche on a un programme pour pouvoir
continuer et amplifier ce que nous avons
fait depuis 2008 il au programme mise au
point par les candidats du parti
socialiste se veut dans la continuité
tout en étant que l'airé précis donc
quatre grandes thématiques sont d'abord
les coupes des habitants un département
protecteur un département attractif et
un département innovants reste
maintenant à convaincre les électeurs
car sur le canton de chalon 3 comme
ailleurs l'abstention est redouté par
l'ensemble des candidats et deux autres
binômes son candidat sur ce canton de
chalon 3 florian 2 tony et jacqueline du
gué pour le front national et daniel
bachelet et brigitte bancaire pour le
front de gauche et on part en côte d'or
pour notre deuxième canton oui c'est le
canton de talent qui illustre bien le
redécoupage avec les communes de talent
et plombières en banlieue dijonnaise et
avec toutes les communes de la vallée de
l'ouche on y trouve deux conseillers
sortants de droite un de gauche et
surtout une droite qui part en ordre
dispersé entre un binôme officielle ump
udi un autre divers droite une division
qui illustre en réalité la violente
opposition entre le président du conseil
général françois sauvadet et le sénateur
ump alain houpert qui soutient lui les
dissidents la gauche elle se présente
unie et le front national entend
profiter de cette élection pour
continuer sa progression
michel gillot et daniel vaccin
voici le maire ump de talent gilbert
menut conseiller général sortant en
campagne à plombières-lès-dijon n'y fait
le canton de talent s'étend jusqu'à
sombernon et comprend les petites
communes rurales de la vallée de l'ouche
marié l'urbain et le rural et donc le
thème de campagne du binôme ump un
binôme qui n'est pas seul à représenter
son camp politique mais qui revendique
sa légitimité
on peut pas empêcher qu'il y ait
d'autres candidatures c'est la seule
démocratie un bien simplement il ya une
liste sont en liste c'est un peu bizarre
mais enfin c'est des listes quand même
officielle qui a les investitures qui
est reconnue il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté là
dessus
après il ya des candidats à peu comment
dire sauvage on va dire comme ça de
gilbert menut a déjà été dissidents aux
élections sénatoriales au mois de
septembre puisqu'il a fait de la
dissidence contre le sénateur sortant
alain houpert voilà il faut savoir que
gilbert menut visait avant tout les
sénatoriales
n'ayant pu être aimé réussir dans dans
l'exercice il s'est rabattu par défaut
sur ces élections départementales donc
c'était pas son souhait et on se pose la
question de sa motivation réelle de se
présenter à ces élections
et voilà pour les chances d'amabilités
au delà de cette querelle pourtant le
même thème de campagne revient
curieusement chez les deux rivaux
contrôler davantage les prestations
sociales
ça c'est un grand sujet déjà débattu au
niveau du conseil général etc où nous
comptons poursuivre pour que l'argent
aille vraiment aux gens qui le méritent
qui renom de soi ça représente plus de
50% du budget du conseil général donc
il est normal et légitime aujourd'hui de
contrôler sérieusement l'ensemble des
prestations sociales qu'on verse aux
citoyens parce qu'elle doit être versée
aux gens qui le méritent et non pas ceux
qui en abusent les impôts à la fiscalité
écrasante voilà un autre thème développé
par alain amis au final c'est donc une
campagne assez droitière qui est menée
par les deux binômes ump et divers
droite serait ce dû à la présence du
front national dans ce camp dont
philippe lowe's a accompagné ici du
candidat fn à auxonne johan bassan
décline la phraséologie habituelle de
son parti premier de france dit-il par
le nombre de candidats présentés
il insiste sur le panier de crabes ump s
et entend défendre les départements dont
la disparition serait programmé le
département est en danger ça veut dire
que j'en profite en même temps pour
avertir les français surtout dans la
ruralité que demain au profit de mega
région le département va va disparaître
et on aura donc des vaisseaux mères qui
seront inaccessibles de nos citoyens et
surtout des français dans la ruralité
profonde un fantasme pour le socialiste
paul robinat certes les futures
compétences de l'assemblée
départementale sont encore en discussion
au parlement
et cela complique la campagne mais
globalement ce conseiller général
sortant prédit que ses attributions
seront très proches de ce qu'elles sont
actuellement on regardera les grandes
compétences comme bien sûr la solidarité
on parlera peut-être le transport on
connaît un peu les bases on est pas on
n'est pas coupée du monde on n'est pas
coupé de la politique on va regarder les
grands les grandes 2 et les grands
dossiers les grandes compétences qui
correspondent au département et ce
qu'attend la population c'est-à-dire la
proximité des dossiers la proximité de
leurs besoins
résumons une gauche unie une droite
désunie et un front national bien décidé
à conforter localement sa dynamique
nationale voilà donc le choix offert aux
électeurs des 34 communes du canton de
talent
et pour illustrer l'opposition qui règne
au sein de la droite côte-d'orienne
voyez ce tweet publié aujourd'hui par un
secrétaire départemental adjoint qui
réclame purement et simplement
l'exclusion de l'ump du sénateur alain
houpert ambiance d'autres tweets mais
plus calme oui à trois jours du premier
tour les réseaux sociaux nous offre
quelques tranches de vie de cette
campagne le candidat sillonnent vraiment
le territoire comme l'ump côte-d'oriens
axel mouffron qui a fait une rencontre
spectaculaire vous le voyez dans un
champ de son canton de longvic pendant
que le candidat modem côte-d'oriens
marianne le vix qui fait lui la sortie
des écoles de son canton pour la bonne
cause bien sûr et c'est pour la bonne
cause aussi que le candidat de droite de
sens gilles purement visite une célèbre
brasserie de son canton pour promouvoir
les sénonais qui osent et puis pour
terminer un autre lieu symbolique cette
fois pour les candidats socialistes de
dijon 5 le célèbre café de l'univers de
la rue berbisey de dijon pour une
réunion publique voilà c'est terminé
pour ce soir
merci prochain journal les élections
demain ici même à demain